bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans cette
faq golden moustache bienvenue dans
l'hypothèse de flaubert à quel
personnage que vous avez joué vous
identifiez vous le plus jamais à quel
identifiez vous le plus dur à dire
surtout que c'est pas écrit brice de
nice avant tout non mais les personnages
de banache et en vrai bah pas du tout
plus tôt il a mis son sexe que s'est il
passé nous en fait c'est juste la vérité
c'est un docu finalement cette vidéo
ouais un dock razak animalier un
document une prise de vue
une vidéo ma mère me mens je pense que
je m'identifie le plus à spider man
parce que j'étais très content de jouer
un rêve d'enfant vont pouvoir implique
vous ça va voilà je veux dire jojo bien
compte linkedin
oh non non non je touche pas ça mais si
celle ci a ouais ouais
et puis c'est bien sûr le père du bien
ça giresse jésus dans l'assemblée
intergalactique pas du tout que je
m'identifie à jésus même si je suis le
fils de dieu mais ça n'a rien à voir
comment je pouvais savoir qu'il marchait
pas sur l'eau mois à quand une nouvelle
chanson qui va me rester en tête va tout
de suite 3 4
maintenant que je prends une guitare or
une guitare s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on
peut me jeter une guitare 3les n'est que
c'est bon les fouilles c'est bon mais
les que c'est bon mais je ne perds de
flaubert est ce que c'est ton vrai nom
ou est ce que c'est un pseudonyme et
pourquoi ce b en majuscules
il verra ce que je m'appelle florent
bernard et que du coup flot de florent
baird bernard et vu que mon nom et une
majuscule au début comme tous les noms
leurs amis de la terre vrai j'ai gardé
est ce qu'il y aura une suite de jojo
golden goose tacitement n'y aura pas
deux il y aura pas de suite à à jojo
je pense qu'il y aura il y aura une
suite
à ma vie
déjà pas mal
ça ne pose pas de souci de supporter les
mac de dole des messages qui sont très
nombreux bah non en soit c'est par un
souci mais juste des fois battu voie
entre deux réunions je fais une petite
sieste et ya une [__] sur mon épaule qui
vient se poser et ça me fait peur parce
que je m'y attendais pas est ce que est
ce que vous allez faire d'autres
parisien ou marseillais entier d'un
choeur oui oui on aimerait bien faire on
a fait il va t on avait eu un traitement
quelles qualités faut-il pour travailler
dans un collectif comme celui ci mais je
dirais des dessins il faut être
volontaire des gros seins genre
peut-être sans cesse proposer des idées
même si vous dites oh là là allait nulle
à chier cette idée folle a proposé quand
même des gros brin parce que d'une idée
nul un autre auteur pour rebondir dessus
vous dire et vous en faire une idée bien
plutôt lite essaie de mettre son égo à
l'entrée de la porte de la réunion
d'auteur pouvons admirer aussi des gens
avec qui on bosse on fait faute pour les
trouver un point de vue extérieur
intéressant artistiquement mais c'est de
pas prendre personnellement si une idée
n'est pas prise et c'est il faut pas
avoir peur justement des critiques qui
d'entre vous est célibataire et qui
d'entre vous êtes en couple je sors
depuis maintenant ça fait six mois dans
sept mois d'ailleurs même je suis très
heureuse que je sors avec franck dubosc
je les ai rencontrés sur le tournage de
disco et depuis c'est le grand amour
vrai ça me fait tellement mieux font du
buzz quel a été votre parcours avant
d'entrer au golden moustache j'ai fait
un bts audiovisuel en option
exploitation j'ai fait une école de
signer à ses chers sur trois ans et
ensuite j'ai fait un conservatoire de
théâtre dans le 5e arrondissement de
paris après j'ai fondé ma boîte avec toi
ouais c'était bien on a filmé des clips
de métal et on a filmé chaïma ce qui
nous a donc appris tout pendant ce temps
là je faisais des vidéos je jouais temps
et je
jean réaliser certaines aux autres j'ai
décidé de créer ma propre web série qui
s'appelle le journal de l'eau et grâce à
ça j'ai été repéré par par françois
descraques jeu que tu te fais beaucoup
beaucoup de courts métrages fait une fac
de cinéma
j'ai rencontré slimane bâtisse meyroune
après j'ai travaillé en tant que monteur
et en parallèle j'écrivais avec julien
jocelyn suricates
ensuite j'ai fait visiteur du futur j'ai
rencontré flaubert et je suis arrivé à
golden star casquette y avez vous
préféré tourner le pet c'est un sketch
lave que j'ai fait est dernière avec 15
taux est donc là vernon et sa part d'une
fille qui doit vivre avec son père qui
était que la taxe
quelle est la vidéo que tu as préféré
réaliser alors je pense que c'est le
bureau des rêves parce qu'il y avait
plein de comédiens fou il ya eu beaucoup
de place pour l'improvisation et parce
que le thème m'était propre et cher et
qu'en plus les gens ont bien apprécié
donc voilà son taf le soul il a pas de
meuf la padanie potiche a pas de petits
chats enfin c'est quoi le rapport à ses
pairs et comportant comme un ami avec
des poils pourquoi golden moustache
alors moi je sais pas mais valentin bon
sens et je suis le seul à voir la
réponse et je vais la donner en
exclusivité aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi le nom gold moustache en
fait c'est très tabou as-tu des conseils
pour un comédien qui débute juste savoir
si tu pense à ça tous les jours
si à chaque fois que tu te lèves à
chaque fois que tu prends ton café
chaque fois que tu marches pense à ça
quelle est la personne la plus relou de
l'équipe pas sans hésiter girex et
adrien meyniel parce qu'il a un genre de
tique un peu agaçant j'adore les fleurs
qui j'aime bien sur youtube
j'aime bien antoine daniel j'aime
beaucoup les chroniques de karim
debbasch je suis très content qu'il ait
recommencé ses chroniques parce que
c'est vraiment très bien
j'aime beaucoup aussi un mec qui
s'appelle nota bene qui fait des vidéos
très intéressante
est il prévu de faire un film avec toute
la team golden moustache est pas prévu
aujourd'hui de faire un film avec latine
grind stoch mais ce serait super cool
oui et d'ailleurs on a un pitch guitare
c'est un scénario inédit sinon je crois
que raphaël raphaël carlier a décidé de
réaliser le remake de disco avec toute
la team de gonnehem moustache raphaël
des cracks jours à franck dubosc bon au
denis gobert évidemment d'un rôle
d'emmanuelle béart gérard depardieu
mcfly j'aimerais beaucoup swaps et dans
le corps d'une femme non pas pour les
raisons lubrique qu'on puisse se dire
mais aussi pour tout apprendre à les
comprendre parce qu'elles ont des choses
différentes à leur arrive des choses
différentes à leur corps elles ont des
propriétés différentes et carrément
découvrir l'orgasme féminin découvrir si
ce que c'est d'avoir d'avoir des règles
d'enfanter peut-être aussi ça peut
carrément être suis pas franchement cool
mais mes super intéressant pour essayer
de se comprendre entre êtres humains
quels sont tes sources d'inspiration
dans l'écriture qui est très travaillé
merci beaucoup
alors que d'inspiration j'en ai plein
kevin smith en termes de dialogue de
personnages de mélange c'est marrant et
en même temps c'est un peu touchant
c'est incroyable giada pato edgar wright
et après il ya plein d'autres films
champ mais qui m'ont grave influencé
et non ça non beaucoup moins en fait pas
du tout je vais me remettre et si
eiffage l'une des normes ieee la faq
terminée dans cette vidéo vous avez
peut-être vu des t-shirts golden stage
des mugs golden moustache qui
appartiennent finalement à golden state
avec et représentent des sketches de
golden moustache et bien vous pouvez les
retrouver sur le store deux cols
démoussage et salue les zigotos bisous à
tous également et ben nous on est super
contents de vous avoir avec nos
quotidiens
continuez de me suivre je vous fais
plein de gros bisous et à très bientôt
salut à tous et carlito c'est moi qui
n'ai eu l'honneur de films et de monter
cette faq alors si elle vous a plu vous
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner et puis
vous avez également l'autorisation
d'aller sur le store de godet moustache
où vous aurez accès à des t-shirts des
posters des mugs et tout vraiment sympa
au quotidien pour avoir artistique la
chevelure